look at this cover right out now from
New York magazine titled when did
everyone become a socialist now we all
know socialism doesn't work now give me
a minute to explain you know the promise
is ah it'll take away all your fears
everything's gonna be free it really
means government takeover of entire
industries here's one example health
care the takeover the health care
industry under socialism Kamala Harris
others Gillibrand you will not be
allowed to own your own private health
care plan they've said so but how much
you want to bet Democrats exempt
themselves and they get to keep their
plans and it's not an exaggeration the
plan is being pushed by Bernie Sanders
Kamala Harris literally eliminates all
private health insurance see with
socialism everyone is promised all your
worries anxieties in life are taken away
and everything is free which they never
keep that promise just think to keep
your doctor keep your plan and pay less
but you do give up one two big things
freedom and liberty in the name of false
security one of the Democrats pushing
this is congresswoman Acacio Cortes and
one of my next guests is calling out the
congresswoman in a green new deal
Patrick Moore he's the former president
of Greenpeace Canada wrote this on
Twitter this weekend iced pompous little
twit you don't have a plan to grow food
for eight billion people without fossil
fuels or get food into cities what
horses
if fossil fuels were banned every tree
in the world would be cut down for fuel
and cooking and eating you would bring
about mass death Patrick Moore joins us
now to explain and he's joining us with
chief meteorologist for weather belt
calm and that is joe Bastardi all right
you know they're kind of going after
your credentials of greens piece which i
think has had a pretty stellar
reputation over the years in spite of my
maybe I personal disagreements I'm an
all-of-the-above guy and believe we
should be good stewards of God's gifts
okay so that would mean all the above
why did you say that on Twitter well
Shawn she's talking about climate change
of course and saying that we have to
eliminate fossil fuels all fossil fuels
cool
oil and natural gas in ten years this
would be basically a suicide pact over
80% of the US and the world's energy
comes from fossil fuels and the only
reason for banning them is the so called
climate apocalypse or climate
catastrophe icao see recruiting young
teachers and whole classes of young
children against the apocalypse they're
saying they're telling these children
that there's going to be an apocalypse
in ten years if they don't save the
climate I think this is child abuse
myself the whole climate change movement
has now reverted to using kids as a
front for not only climate change and
ending the use of fossil fuels but the
whole ball of wax about socialism I
think that's really what they're trying
to sell Patriot is interesting you say
that there was a really cute girl on on
60 minutes last night
that's suing the federal government
apparently this lawsuits been going on
for four years and as I listened you
know clearly she believes everything and
and I agree in the sense that it's very
apocalyptic Joe Bastardi one thing I
love about you is you can tell me what
was the big storm in 1903 and where it
happened and why it happened and what
the conditions were that caused it to
happen and compare it to today and
you've been saying that almost the same
thing as Patrick Moore well yeah I say
the same thing 1903 by the way Atlantic
City got hit by a hurricane from the
southeast remember so glad you brought
up I was show off yeah you know what I
saw the the new green deal Sean I
thought it was a Saturday Night Live
skit you know drunk uncle spouting off
like oh we're going to build railroads
across the ocean let's build one to the
moon we could put a restaurant up there
great food but no atmosphere be a vegan
restaurants though the whole thing is
meant to get you to try to fight against
an extreme position while there's
incremental creeping of this and Patrick
Justice dr. Bohr justice described it
what they're doing to kids are
indoctrinating kids where were those
kids be if we did not have the fossil
fuel era the true hockey sticks or the
fossil fuel error
life expectancy the amount of people on
the planet and personal GDP they're all
skyrocketing it's almost like these
people are ungrateful for what got them
here you know you think about it will
eliminate cows cars as we know them
airplanes Patrick uh you know how are we
gonna get to Europe we're gonna take a
sailboat are we gonna take a high-speed
train know what you're gonna build above
or below the water you know so my
question Patrick to you is is it natural
gas one of the cleaner-burning gases out
there aren't there ways we can improve
the environment simultaneously while
also using the lifeblood of every
economy that feeds everybody as you
rightly point out well Shawn we've
actually improved the cleanliness of all
the fossil fuels coal oil the vehicle
emissions today are less than 90 percent
you know have been improved by more than
90 percent from what they were decades
ago and you know we could use more
nuclear energy for producing the
electricity that would that's true and
hydroelectric but funny they're against
both of those two which are the only two
really reliable cost-effective
technologies that could replace fossil
fuels and you know we could put nuclear
reactors in the big ships just like the
Russians whole icebreaker fleet and
nuclear navies are powered with nuclear
we could do that so there are some
places where we could reduce fossil fuel
but when it comes to transportation and
also agriculture food and moving people
and goods around if you stop moving the
food into the cities people in the
cities will starve they can't grow their
food in Manhattan enough for all those
people in the high-rises so not enough
tomato pops I agree or no flam if I'm
gonna get the last word to Joe but story
about 15 seconds Joe you get to close
this up if you if you take a look at the
entire history of the plane at the 10
billion years who however far you want
to go back this would be the first time
that man is controlling the climate I
tend to doubt that that is the case all
right thank you both so important
everybody hear the other side here even
from greens piece all right